[Music]
besides him to go did it alright also
that I know that she's no danger to
anybody whatsoever cannot inspires you
cannot little cockroach but you made a
mistake and have to live with the
consequences and I know I'm nobody
special a hundreds and hundreds of
people go through this all yo Dee
Chesney was just 17 years old she was in
a park with her friends in East London
when she was stabbed in the back
[Music]
her death puts pressure on the police
and politicians to tackle the growing
problem of knife crime
I spoke to Jodi's father Peter she
really was just the nicest person ever
she would have done anything to deserve
this no way she will have done anything
to deserve this
so I just hope you know someone knows
who did this
yeah somebody knows who did this just do
the right thing you know you never know
the pain that you've caused
and the beauty taken away you know means
it they've destroyed something beautiful
here and it's just the disgrace and that
just just please somebody who knows
about this just do the right thing just
get this go at it what do you know about
what happened the last time I spoke to
her was Friday morning on my birthday
she got up to wish me happy birthday
before when I work and then so yeah so
she's in there she was out of her
friends and we were celebrating some of
her and what do I know about the attack
I know it was a stab wound to the back a
long knife and um and she bled to death
literally in the ambulance what'd you
say to him what would I say to him come
on don't say anything to him the guy who
did it
oh no answer that but if he's watching
or from somebody is watching hmm you
want them to do the right thing as you
said I thought no if anything I'm gonna
say he's gonna install any conscience on
this guy about it if you have any
conscience or whatever and you have any
heart and you're seen what's going on
here and what you've taken the right and
the pain you've caused and a beauty
you've taken away from this world just
just just give yourself up if you've got
any condition whatsoever honestly it's
the pan of pain there this guy's caused
and then the stir the soul they siphon
off and swim away from us
he's crazy it's crazy
[Music]
Sky News has met the Islamic state
fighter who's married to Shamima Begum
and he told us they made the wrong
decision
joining the terrorists Jager radix said
they were brainwashed and wanted to join
is to help the people of Syria
tell me about Samira Begum when did you
meet her I met her in Raqqa and I think
2015 yeah and what happened then was
just a story of did you fall in love
with her what happened how did you
basically what happened is a friend of
mine approached me and he said I know
you do are interested in marriage a girl
she was a who just came she was looking
for a husband would you like to meet her
initially I wasn't really interested
because of her young age but how old was
she she was back then 15 she was 50 yes
I wasn't a problem a little bit that's
why I was a bit reluctant she was a
child you married a child kind of and
both of you was supportive of this
enterprise was terror enterprise the
Islamic state every son all you have to
be basically if you have a negative
attitude against towards the Islamic
state it's a very dangerous thing they
will consider you a rebel they will
arrest you they will probably torture
you might even kill you what was her
reaction to the Islamic state how did
she find living on the water would you
have considered her wish you a good
Islamic wife if she was a good Islamic
wife she basically she stayed in how she
took care of me she took care of her
children but besides that she did not
really have a lot to do basically she
had nothing to do with this Lamech State
should never have any direct contact
besides her friends with anybody working
with Islamic state besides me the
British government has revoked her
[ __ ] what do you think about that
I find that saddens me because it will
make her situation very difficult of
course and me I know her very well I
bring my wife for more than three years
I know that she's no danger to anybody
whatsoever
she cannot conspire she cannot real
cockroach but you made a mistake and
would have to live with the consequences
Anthony Brian is a child of the Windrush
generation he was locked in detention
centers and nearly deported the Home
Office has been criticized for the way
Anthony and many others were treated
he's received an official apology but
little else he told me about the impact
its had on his life they don't give us
that they did better suicide
eight months eight months in say they
say they're gonna do the art ship fund
and I need nothing so we just put there
to wait no because if they don't tell us
we won't know and there's not good going
up in a minute arks and then was I
happening is they think it's just money
you want to be honest who do need some
money
he would help so obviously there were
these big gestures when it started amber
Rudd had to resign then Sajid Javid
promised that he was going to tackle it
what do you think of it ain't nothing
not not being done nothing could I see
anyway he write few letters and make a
few gestures that don't help us you know
and here always gonna purge in fear and
all this I can't see it I cannot see I
get so frustrated when he speaks and
survived in Russian and the conversation
I just
besides another another eight months
Chris Bryant has been a Labour MP for
nearly two decades in that time serving
as the shadow leader of the House of
Commons and the shadow culture secretary
he's just undergone surgery at a
hospital in Wales to remove a cancerous
mole on the back of his head he told me
he was first prompted to go and get the
mill checked following a trip to the
barbers it was quite literally the
haircut that saved his life I had my
hair cut really short because we were
going away at Christmas and I needed it
to last for six weeks and shorter than
you would normally yes exactly and Jared
my husband went and what's that which
was a like a mole tiny little mole which
was a little bit I've never seen it but
I gather it was a bit red and a bit
black and a bit yellow so that's what it
was makes him disturbing so on my
birthday I was driving past the doctor's
surgery import them in there on my
decisions he and I yeah I thought well
maybe I should just go in because I've
you know I've heard of all these stories
and so I went in and he said oh well I
think that's probably a wart but I'll
send you under the special two-week
guarantee thing I'll send you off to the
specialist so I went to the
dermatologist wonderful woman called
Julie Martin dr. Julie Martin she said I
think that's the melanoma to be honest
is not a wart
she was sitting behind a desk with a
file open and that I thought this isn't
great and then she was very simple and
straightforward she said you have a
stage 3b melanoma so there's four stages
of melanoma I'm not I'm not a medical
expert but and I knew that three was not
good and I you know I just
so hey it feels like being noticed fine
it's fine fine and we have that tea
please
it feels like being punched in the
stomach and I know I'm nobody special
hundreds and hundreds of people go
through this all the time you know
there'll be people having this exactly
today and the only reason I want to talk
about it really is well in a sense and I
have no choice because it's so obvious
people point at me on the train and I'll
be appearing in the next production of
Frankenstein at the National without any
makeup that but um you know you do want
to cry and I felt cold in my skin for 48
hours and you know I slept terribly that
night and I imagined everything I was
gonna be dead by the end of the week I
was not gonna make it to Easter and
every single tin twinge in my body was
another form of cancer and they were
gonna discover when I went forward for
the next thing that you know I I was
riddled with it since then I've now had
they do a an ultrasound on all your
lymph nodes around your neck and stuff
because that would be where it'd be most
likely to go to first and they do a scan
of your CT scan of your body both of
those were all clear and the chunk that
they took out to do that they only took
out that much so that the bit that looks
like a little bit of pork scratching is
from my side so you they take a bit from
here and they and you may have seen an
earlier picture so that the bit that's
on the screen yeah
that it that sort of heart bit all the
bit on the left yeah that's there's the
graft yeah and and that probably won't
have hair on it but the rest of it the
rest of it will and I mean you can see
already that it's healing amazingly
quickly it's a bit bloody but
[Music]
so I mean at the moment all the
prognosis is really good now she's one
of the loudest voices in the me2
movement actress Rose McGowan sparked an
avalanche of sexual assault allegations
in the entertainment industry
and beyond Hollywood gives us a really
narrow mirror to view ourselves in and
it's it's kind of one-dimensional
but it affects so many and it is a form
of propaganda and way sort of sexism are
we talking about it's sort of not just
sexism it's like hey here's what you are
as a man here's what you're as a woman
here's what you are as a transgender
here's what you are as anything and the
problem is is that it's 96% men and the
Directors Guild that's all the directors
and that statistic hasn't changed since
1946
so it's just a very narrow view and and
it operates you know Hollywood operates
in secrecy not a lot of people know what
really goes on there it's kind of you
know it's an illusion really it's like
it's supposed to be glamorous supposed
to be all these things and behind the
scenes that can be really tragic and
really traumatic
it can also be great but for me I was
discovered so I was never trying to be
an actress and and it was it was it was
a hard road so do you consider yourself
now on the outside looking in at that
industry and I'm intrigued as to what
you think of the people who are inside
that industry I I'm definitely on the
outside looking in whereas before I was
both a person in society on the outside
and also very much on the inside but I
what do I think about it I think they're
really fear-based and I I wish they'd be
braver with us now is just for that
she's the Labour MP for Birmingham
Yardley and she's written a series of
tweets to the prime minister and the
education secretary as someone angry
tweets asking to explain why her son's
primary school is closing earlier on
Fridays in response and apart for
Education spokesman said we have
protected the core schools budget
overall in real terms since 2010 and put
an additional 1.3 billion into course
schools funding across 2018-19
and 20 19 20 over and above plans set
out at the last spending review are you
sure that this is necessary that your
son's primary school shuts early on
Friday because of money yes absolutely
it's not a new phenomenon it's been
talked about at my son's school for
nearly two years now about to talk about
they have hundreds of thousands of
pounds of deficit that cannot be made up
and this is because of things like
special educational needs children
there's lots of disabled children at my
son's school and as well as the cut that
they're suggesting making into the
school hours that stops them having to
have support staff there and stops them
having to have cover support for
teachers to plan which they have to do
they're also suggesting that they will
no longer be able to facilitate disabled
children in my son's school so a
cleansing of disabled you see one of the
reason why I'm asking is another
Birmingham school said it was going to
close on Friday lunchtime so teachers
could do their paperwork it seemed you
make a political point if you like well
there's 15 I think about 15 schools in
Birmingham in total so it's if the the
DFA and they're frankly completely out
of touch statement which is just
insulting to me as a parent and they
should be careful because I'm not here
necessarily just talking as an MP I'm
talking as an angry parent and there are
millions of us out there
[Music]
Keith Flint has been described as a true
pioneer innovator and legend by his
prodigy bandmates following the news of
his death at the age of 49 I think the
thing that made the prodigy so impactful
and the reason they connected in such a
big way from from the very beginning was
that they there was just total
authenticity from day one and I think
that low-keyed started as a dancer you
know the power of that group groove
through through those some first few
years of the nineties and the body of
work they put out between the the
experience albums of fat of the land at
those three albums across five years was
that were absolute game changer and it
should become you know they're right up
there with with some of the best albums
made of all time
[Music]
[Music]
I'm here in the Indian Ocean where Sky
News is involved in a project to explore
the deep sea to evaluate the impact of
climate change and plastic pollution I
spoke to the president of the Seychelles
who accused world leaders of being blind
to the risk Danny Ford joined me on the
ocean Zephyr the mothership for the
nekton mission that will use
submersibles to survey the reefs of the
twilight zone in the tropical
archipelago I addressed the the g7 in
June last year you know I went to
Aldabra where where this ship will be
going and I was there in December 27 17
for the first time I saw what is
happening you know the islands is like a
trap so we have we have plastics from
all over coming into into Seychelles and
creating the damage and I show them the
pictures of what is happening and they
all looked at me and as a result of my
my advocacy and tough talk Norway has
been the first country together with the
World Bank to put a sum of 200 million
and this is not enough I think
governments they need to take the
responsibility you know we cannot
destroy our oceans sea shells is such a
beautiful country it is paradise on
earth and our inhabitants we are
guardians of this paradise we keep it
for Humanity
and we just need to stop it
you haven't heard much from Adam re-park
for a couple of Instagram post since
it's tearful press conference and a big
operation but he's on the road to
recovery
Wimbledon might be too soon but he is
gonna try and get back to top level
tennis this is what he said to me where
I put up with him at Queen's Club how is
the bionic hip yes it's going well so
far I mean I'm in no pay and when I'm
walking around and stuff so you know
that was the the reason for having there
the operation the first place so I feel
just feel a lot happier in my in myself
on a daily basis and yeah it feels it
feels pretty good take us back to the
table press conference because you must
have been at a very low point to speak
like that to speak about the end of your
career I don't think people realize how
much pain you're in what was the thought
process well I mean basically for the
last kind of 12 18 months you know as an
athlete and kind of competitor when
people ask you you know how you're
getting on at competitions and stuff you
you're not going to say all my hips
terrible because you might be playing
them the next week or you know I'm
trying to be optimistic when I'm getting
asked about my hip and press conferences
and stuff and you know but I I was
struggling you know I was struggling for
a long time and you could see that and
just the way I was walking around in
terms of you know limping it everywhere
I was going so it was it was tough and
in that press conference obviously I
kind of spoke from my heart a little bit
and kind of opened up and it had been it
been tough kind of 18 months so I felt
much better after I'd done it and
obviously had the operation now and I
feel good and how's the last month been
has it been tough the rehab how do you
feel it's been I mean rehabs never loads
of fun I mean it's look it's quite quite
tedious a little bit boring and I've
done a bunch of different stints of
rehab over the last 18 months so but
because I'm seeing progress now and
because I'm not in pain it's sort of
motivating me each day to be doing it
because I'm noticing that things are
getting better and I don't have to limp
anymore and you know my hip feels feels
good which hadn't been the case the last
18 months I've been doing rehab and my
hip
still really saw it so you know now I'm
seeing some some good signs and yeah
positive about the outcome you couldn't
tie your shoelaces before can you do
that now I still can't do that yet but
that's more through stiffness and stuff
from the operation rather than rather
than pain but I'm getting there I can
just about do it still got these slip-on
shoes on just now which which which
helped but it's not often that our
guests get away with running around our
studio and licking their glass but will
forgive little ila and Jemima marine
before they were born
the twins were diagnosed with a rare
blood imbalance which gave them just a
5% chance of survival the girls and
their parents came in for a chat on a
plane this is Ayla that's too much they
want to wander around it's absolutely
fine don't worry about it while we're
having a chat
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
maybe we'll see in just a second